if you're like me you've probably
noticed that nostalgia is usually only
skin-deep once you peel away the
immediate gratification of something
warm and familiar there's usually not
much left beneath the surface and
despite my urge to do so for the longest
time I refuse to review this film until
I thought enough time had passed
I wanted to judge this story on its
merits and not on my rose-tinted love
for it and the franchise had represented
I wanted to know if a curatorial his
third outing into the movie world was as
great as I thought it was I wanted to
peel away the surface level nostalgia to
see if there was something of substance
within toy animations greatest
box-office smash hit looking into the
story the music and the visuals I wanted
to write an honest review for the 2018
film Dragon Ball super
Broly
[Music]
as I was going on I never really enjoyed
the Dragon Ball movies I would always
give him a shock but they never captured
my interest the same way the anime did
while trying to watch these films I
always thought that they were rushed
unearned versions of the anime story in
miniature the visuals and action
sequences looked really cool across the
board but the story seems secondary and
because of that it never really
interested in fact I didn't end up
seeing all of these to the end until TFS
redid them decades later
that is until battle of gods and
resurrection F changed everything we now
had standalone stories that worked as
films battle of gods was the first
Dragon Ball film I enjoyed beginning to
end and resurrection F was fun on first
viewing at the very least despite it
being a less enjoyable film to me
overall and needless to say with Dragon
Ball super anime over and a new film
slated on the horizon I was more than
excited then it was announced to be a
bro Li movie which had a lot of folks
like myself worried a character like bro
Lee taking center stage was nothing new
to the Dragon Ball films and to be
perfectly honest I saw him always as a
condensed version of everything I hated
about those old Dragon Ball films all
appearance no substance but primarily
what made me anxious and many others was
the prospect of making a character like
bro Lee Canada however soon after much
of the negative hearsay surrounding the
film vanished as Toriyama made a formal
announcement reassuring us all that he
was rewriting bro Lee's character as
well as handling the film script
personally additionally three
interesting and impressive trailers
dropped demonstrating some incredible
visuals with the promise of an
interesting origin story but did it live
up to that promise the beginning of this
film is extremely efficient streamlined
and surprisingly accessible for the 20th
film in a franchise that spans decades
and while there are tons of tiny nods to
past events technologies and lore for
the longtime fans to enjoy the film
takes specific care in establishing the
key players and motivations of the film
being told beginning with a flashback 41
years in the past we are greeted with
shots of the freeze of force in its
heyday the jinyu's star Vaughn tutoria
king called and a young Frieza are all
present taking place in the same home
world before us destruction this is the
first look we get at the Society of the
Saiyans written by
Kirra toriyama in animation and it's
honestly terrific there's a tremendous
sense of scale at awe as King Cole's
army arrives on planet Vegeta
this is the single most important moment
of the sands history up until this point
and we feel that in the dialogue that's
delivered the spectacular angles on
display and the expressions of the
people it's the perfect place to start
this film and it's the event that
triggers every major choice that drives
this story forward from here on in
immediately it's instantly recognizable
that the visuals have underwent a
significant upgrade from the wobbly
outlines vibrant colors lighting and
nostalgic character designs this film
feels and looks more like dragon ball
than anything that's been released in
the last 10 years at least bring
characters closer to how the original
artist envisioned them enhancing their
expressions and personalities through
exaggerated movements and close-ups it's
honestly a feast for the eyes that you
can only fully appreciate when watching
it for yourself
the first scene acts as a passing of the
torch and a coronation of sorts for
Frieza as he accepts his father's
position as the leader of his forces
immediately setting a ruthless and
sinister tone effortlessly brushing
aside the Saiyans plans to stop him with
a simple tech demonstration humiliated
and frustrated we follow King Vegeta as
he visits his son in the nursery with
the hopes that he one day will carry out
his revenge on Frieza with a father
impressing motivations like this it's
it's easy to see how Vegeta's childhood
made him the man he is today however
this isn't Vegeta scene it's broglie's
revealed as a lower-class warrior with
an exceptionally high battle potential
the exposition bully receives is
incredibly natural and believable as the
doctors try to justify his placement in
this particular nursery to the king all
the while he struggles to accept the
fact that his son might not be the best
choice to overthrow Frieza
and this is the film's strength the
motivations established in these early
scenes drive and inform the subsequent
ones in natural and believable ways King
Vegeta is threatened by Broly upstaging
his son and being a danger to the same
race therefore he is exiled ultimately
to a remote planetoid called vampa
broglie's father para gas naturally
takes issue with this and immediately
flees after his son to save him breeding
and lifelong grudge
that ultimately becomes the driving
force for all the conflict in the second
half of this film the visuals of broli
landing and vampa as a small Opie for
the film stunning visuals lighting color
and music concluding with the single
best Tyler drop I've ever seen in a
Dragon Ball film there's just something
so satisfying about it we are only 10
minutes into the film and we have
already established all of this this is
honestly excellent pacing in traveling
to vampa para gas common dere's a ship
piloted by another Saiyan called beats
that regrettably gets wrapped up in all
of this however once they find Broly
they realized that the escape pod they
use to get to Planet vampa was
irreversibly damaged in the crash
removing all options of leaving the
planet thereafter once para gues
discovers that there's no way out
he immediately removes beats from the
equation to save food as cold-heartedly
as you can imagine shooting a laser
straight through the Saiyans chest this
is where we leave bro Lee's story for
the time being and move some years into
the future
where we find the first controversial
section of the film the following 10
minutes cover the events derived from a
one-shot manga written and illustrated
by Akira Toriyama
called Dragon Ball - when screenshots
from trailers suspiciously similar to -
surfaced online a wave of worries
swelled across the fan base that was
palpable but to be perfectly honest it
plays out much better than I first
expected it to at least with that said
there are some negative takeaways from
this section the most glaring of which
being Goku's true origin while it works
incredibly well within this film and
significantly better than in - is comic
it's still difficult not to constantly
see the Superman parallels once you
first notice it the film does make
considerable efforts to integrate new
elements of the Dragon Balls story into
the classic Canon succeeding
fantastically in some cases while not so
much in others for everything else in
the scene it works exceptionally well
even instances in the - comic that I
disliked like Bardock suspicion of
Frieza made much more sense here than it
did in the manga giving legitimate
believable grounds for him to suspect
something off Frieza rather than him
just having an unexplained feel
additionally this is one of the first
scenes that works substantially better
having prior knowledge of the series
after being introduced to the elites
nursery that housed Vegeta and Broly
Goku situation is far more modest
there's something heartwarming and
special about it
kept locked away in an old capsule at
the back of their house no one not even
his parents knowing what he will do with
his life moments like that accompanied
by the stunning visuals and breathtaking
heartbreaking scores lifts this section
of the film higher than my wildest
dreams ever expected in a surprisingly
touching scene Goku is sent off the
doomed planet by his parents Frieza
charges his blast Bar Doc's prediction
comes to pass and were greeted by a
montage of moments from Goku's life as
both he and Vegeta fight into the
present day easily missed in this quick
flash of iconic moments is a young
parolee minding his own business
surviving as both Goku and Vegeta get to
experience their lives this is a film
about these three characters and how
their fates have been in some shape or
form connected our large criticism
people have thrown this film's way has
been its exclusion of fan favorite
characters like go on and piccolo and
while I do love these characters I think
the decision to keep the cast focused
and uncluttered grant to the film the
breathing room it needed to flesh out
this story but it's not without its
flaws and I'll get to that
with that we're almost thirty minutes
into the story and this is where I start
seeing things that bothered me slightly
small things admittedly but they still
exist essentially to get all of these
major players in the same area to fight
one another the Dragon Ball has become
involved Frieza appoints men to steal
them from boneless place which they do
with ease because plot needs to happen
and naturally goku and vegeta are
conveniently not there to intervene
additionally and also conveniently boma
only gathered six Dragon Balls which
gives Goku and Vegeta a means of
tracking them down before they find the
last one this honestly is all very
contrived done this pretty weak
storytelling thankfully the means with
which Broly and para guests are rescued
from bomba makes much more sense in the
context of its story characters and
things Chi lie and Lemmo two new
characters introduced for this story are
recruits with in the freeze of force
tasked with locating strong power
signatures to recruit into the freeze of
force those fire every scene concerning
Broly has been this film's strongest
aspect
as honestly it should be he is the
titular character after all and
thankfully this praise train continues
as he builds a wonderful relationship
with level and the wonderful chili and
all of these scenes were Broly interacts
with Frieza his father chili and the
crew of the ship are fantastic through
the revelation of his past as well as
his father's cruelty we develop a deep
sympathy for him and the situation he
has grown up with it's revealed that
Broly has been controlled using a shock
collar this is an interesting idea that
comes with some tragic visuals both from
the act of shocking Broly himself and
the expressions on his face once he
seized the remote that turns the collar
on what doesn't make sense to me is why
he just doesn't take the collar off I
mean he already in a calm state has a
power level in excess of 100 thousand
according to Chia a Scouter so I think
he can break some metal around his neck
now that aspect of the film did bother
me quite a bit especially when you
consider that it's a vital part of what
makes or breaks the film but I digress
in an effort to protect Broly from his
father's cruelty chill I steal the
remote Paris uses to restrain his son as
both the forces of Frieza and earth set
themselves on a collision course it's
now only a matter of time before all
three main characters clash for the
first time fated for this meeting this
fight goes on for almost 40 minutes and
it's not only the best Dragon Ball has
ever looked but it's one of the most
visually impressive sequences of
animation I have ever seen the
ridiculous amount of effort that went
into this film if it wasn't clear before
it most certainly should be now and
while I'm sure many of you will be
familiar with this fight I'm gonna try
to break it down and maybe point out a
few things here and there that you might
have missed the fight itself can be
divided into three sections with each
section serving a particular purpose
within the story
Broly versus vegeta to kick things off
Broly versus goku that takes up the
middle section and finally Gogeta vs.
Broly to end everything and it just so
happens that each of these three
sections focuses on the unique strengths
of each individual fight for instance a
vegeta fight is most entertaining when
he is styling on his opponent and in
control of
action we don't often get to enjoy
sequences like this but when Vegeta
receives the first punch from broli
and gives us that cheeky grin we know
what's coming and we know how good this
is gonna be the Vegeta fight takes up
about eight minutes of the overall
fights runtime and Yuya Takahashi is in
charge of this section within which we
get to enjoy the shock fall across the
faces of both Broly and para gasp as
Vegeta introduces the Super Saiyan and
Super Saiyan God transformations to the
fight and my god are they handled
beautiful I specifically love the Super
Saiyan transformation as he begins to
glow refusing to let go of broglie's
hand before being enveloped in a massive
golden aura with the camera panning 360
degrees around his stance it's beautiful
this fight however serves one important
purpose primarily to bring Broly
up to speed both figuratively and
literally with the level of combat the
main cast is on through breathtakingly
beautiful tracking shots
Broly slowly gains the upper hand of
vegeta until he finally overpowers the
Saiyan Prince before losing his mind the
fight from here quickly shifts focus to
Goku and Broly again the script clearly
understands that Vegeta is most fun to
watch what he's performing in a dominant
fashion and Goku is most interesting
when he's on the back foot and thus this
transition came at the perfect time
this Goku section is handled primarily
by animator reel on a she who is also
the artist to animated the very first
teaser released for Dragon Ball super
burly and demonstrates some really
experimental animation that I really
enjoyed where the Vegeta fight
established all the regular things we've
come to expect from the series in a
fantastic fashion Goku's fight
introduces new takes on the franchise
through its music selection animation
and lore the music up until this point
of the film has been phenomenal however
much the battle tracks are something you
will either love or hate Sumitomo the
man responsible for the music of the
film felt inspired by the live event
gatherings in latin america during the
final episodes of Dragon Ball super and
so wanted to add chanting and a hype man
for lack of a better term to the tracks
in this section
I enjoyed the experimental nature of it
and if nothing else it's most certainly
memorable from an animation perspective
we got to enjoy a first-person tracking
shot perspective the likes of which I
honestly never seen before in Dragonball
I thought it was a fun idea and worked
well in this long fight to help break up
the monotony on the action but wasn't
majorly impressed and could even see a
lot of people missing this sequence if
you weren't looking for it the fight
itself lasts about 12 minutes in total
for Olli and Goku it has some
interesting new techniques and even has
an explosive Super Saiyan blue
transformation in the middle of things
it does have a few moments of CGI here
and there but with the battle itself
being almost 40 minutes long I'm willing
to forgive the little CGI that was
involved in fact I'd even go as far as
to say that in many other aspects of the
film CGI was used to enhance sequences
beyond what it would have been without
it through backgrounds special effects
and filters amidst all of this action
and explosion para ggest now injured
from being too close reveals to freeze
that that bro Lee must be at his limit
now fortunately Frieza has the perfect
contingency plan
packed with being a magnificent scene
rich in character for Frieza it's also
an almost mirror image of how para Gus
casually killed beats in cold blood
earlier in the film due to the sudden
loss of his father brouilly
overcome with grief begins to transform
during which there's an incredible shot
of Frieza standing front and center
surrounded by flames and destruction all
of his own doing something of interest
also during this cut is that Brawley
blasts his father's body away out of
view never to be seen again in the film
with the situation now more dire than
ever
Vegeta rejoins a fight in what is a
surprisingly effective CGI sequence some
terrific angles backroads choreography
and even angles we wouldn't normally see
in traditional 2d animation overwhelmed
by the hulking enraged Saiyan
both Vegeta and Goku in one of the
funniest moments of the film pond
brewing off on Frieza before making
their way to piccolo somewhere else on
earth using Instant Transmission this
scene is pretty much ripped straight out
of fusion Report and honestly after all
Vegeta has been through in Super with
Goku this scene didn't make sense to me
Vegeta for whatever reason still has a
problem fusing with Goku
understands that it's only 30 minutes
and he understands that he can't do it
any other way
I just honestly can't understand this
hang-up he has he's just fought
alongside Goku in the tournament of
power as well as 30 seconds ago
he's even danced before to save his
friends in battle of gods why is this of
all things an issue for him
simply put because it gives them a
chance to make jokes and to create fake
tension there's really no other reason
I would have preferred if Vegeta showed
the emotional maturity to bring the idea
forth to Goku first that would have been
interesting and a first for the
character needless to say the two of
them agreed to fuse eventually but all
these botched fusion attempts basically
translates to Frieza getting pummeled
for the bones of about an hour before
they eventually arrive as the newly
fused Gogeta makes his Canon debut in
the film now after almost 90 minutes of
the movie having seen some of the most
spectacular animation we've ever seen
from the series one would think that
we've already seen all this film can
show us however nothing could be further
from the truth the remainder of this
fight is packed to bursting with not
only the best animation Dragon Ball has
ever seen but some of the best action
animation I've ever seen period Naruto
shishi that contributes around 1 minute
in 40 seconds of pure movement to the
beginning of this fight and it's
spectacular but seeing as this is an
honest review I do have one small gripe
while everything looks fantastic and
clean the fact that Natasha Sheeta is
held in such high regard within the
company he works for means that he gets
to board his own section which has one
unfortunate side-effect he ends up
repeating angles techniques and
sequences almost exactly the same way
over and over again multiple times
during this sequence I recognize the
composition and ideas from earlier works
and super I'm guessing this isn't
something the regular viewer would even
notice but I did and I thought it worth
mentioning regardless of this small
gripe I still love this spectacular
color of animation from The Incredible
no Toshi cheetah also within this
section is the third and final CGI
sequence but honestly it's the best one
and suits the dimensional shift both
characters undergo its honestly stunning
something also of note once
Cheeta turns Super Saiyan blue rolling
neverland's a hit on him after while
this phenomenal fight is taking place my
last major problem with the film rears
its head she lies desire to save Rolly
by putting her life at risk this leap
from her while I understand it seems a
little premature she already paid Rolly
back for standing up for her after she
stole the remote away from Paris and
while I believed that her and Burleigh
have a fondness for one another that is
believable I find she lies particular
decision here kind of unbelievable this
is a narrative thread that I thought
could have greatly benefited from having
more time exploring it the film did make
a concerted effort to build the
relationship up in three separate scenes
and while I did love their Tarzan and
Jane dynamic they still only knew each
other for a few hours the remaining
moments of the fight are again filled
with some of the most spectacular
animation I've ever seen from Dragonball
full of amazing choreography callbacks
to prior films and character rich
moments the final moments of the battle
are made even more tense with the use of
the Dragon Balls causing the world to be
shrouded in darkness as Gaggia charges
his final kamehameha Broly looks
genuinely scared like he's suddenly come
out of a trance he's beaten and I
sincerely really liked that inclusion
the wish is made to transport Brody back
to home all is back to normal once again
and the fight is over and so now that
everything has been said and done these
are my final thoughts this film really
isn't perfect and as I pointed out has
its shortcomings narrative Lee it isn't
a flawless film and while the first half
does a fantastic job delivering
exposition for first time viewers the
second half really takes off the
training wheels going full force with
its lore and combat so why don't I think
this is the most accessible Dragon Ball
film to date I still would assume that
for most people unfamiliar with the
series prior knowledge of it is required
to get a relatively mediocre level of
enjoyment out of it when all is said and
done however what did I think of it as a
fan of the series I've honestly never
had more fun watching a film to say that
this movie takes you on a ride is an
understatement of the highest order
the fanservice the characters the story
the ridiculous action sequences and set
pieces it's plain as day that the
animators musicians artists writers and
everyone involved we're going
all out with this film it's taken the
best elements from Dragon Ball -
brouilly the legendary Super Saiyan and
fusion reborn to create a brand new
story that is far superior than the sum
of its parts it's not a perfect film and
it has its problems but the
exceptionally great parts of this movie
far outweigh its drawbacks and I highly
recommend anyone who hasn't seen this to
experience it for themselves thanks for
watching
[Music]